what are you uh what are you listening
to lately man like what is kind of in
your I mean you brought up Morgan Wallen
you listen to Country I listen to
everything you listen to some country
like music suck nowadays it does me and
Neil were just talking about it bro I go
to all my other interviews you know I've
been waiting to get here bro all right
well you were late so yeah I go to all
my I was waiting for you
I got all my other interviews and I'm
like yeah which I do love these artists
the artists that I name I [__] with
these artists but I don't really like
nowadays I don't really like music these
days
I saw it's all like um
saw the same stuff I think what's going
on is I like some of the songs though no
some for sure but I think this is what's
dope about favorite song is it's a
record and I feel like most artists
nowadays they're not they're they're
very they're just throwing together
joints sometimes there's like a half a
hook this is like a [__] wreck music
is not how it used to be right music
used to be like you know hits after hits
after hits like real hits like some [__]
you wake up to and it's playing on the
TV in the morning uh MTV and
[__] [__] that you like like it
was real hits right like
this [__] like [__] it's the cousin
rapping it's the streaming [__] it's
like hey man I got plaques off of this
streaming yeah bro like everybody trying
to do it and which is cool but like
that's why I thought it was dope to like
I feel like Dirk
my homeboy start just started rapping
this [__] I love him to death he got he
gotta leave that [__] alone
yeah that [__] ain't nothing did you
tell him that yeah no he's telling me I
love him though I'm gonna tell him he's
gonna watch this well yeah he gonna see
this [__] he gonna see this [__] this is
my homeboy too is this hard is it hard
to because it is very I'm sure I've been
told his ass don't do that [__] though
did you tell him he's not good though
yes listen we used to Freestyle and I
used to tell him like bro
don't do this [__] this [__] ain't for
you but he ain't never used to try out
of nowhere he started trying it's like
he was playing around and now he's like
yeah you made it bro I was in the cipher
with you bro I could do it too you know
that [__] ain't none he having fun with
it though that's what I love about it
but this [__] ain't like don't don't
waste your time trying to do this [__]
and you could be doing others I've had a
lot of close friends I have a cousin
who's been he's older than me he's been
rapping for 20 years and I've told him a
million times this is
because I don't know what you're doing
bro at this point you just buying studio
time yeah I know I know a few people
like that though it's like at what point
in time do you pull the Band-Aid off and
go get a job nah never you know they're
gonna keep this [__] rolling though
man you should be the guy to be like
honest oh yeah I got to be honest yeah
you are you sometimes your honesty it
gets you in trouble at times yeah
sometimes
are you still uh are you still in a
relationship are you single what's going
on yeah yeah I'm still in a relationship
you kind of kicked back from like
posting your girl too much because
before I feel like you were out there
with it yeah is there a reason like why
like
um
it's just too personal yeah I don't want
people in my business yeah let him let
him listen to the [__] album if they
want to know your business yeah I mean
y'all listen to not sure if you want if
you want to hear about nazare listen to
Niger it's a pretty wild first name I
love it yeah I don't know where the [__]
my mom got that from what I was about to
say is that a one-of-one type in first
name yeah you don't even know my
sibling's name so please tell me Niger
and menajah
she a Nicki Minaj fan nah hell nah yes
she is actually yeah yeah she is but I
thought you meant like Nicki Minaj fan
like is that where she got it from nah
menajah manager okay nominage
yeah like Tracy so Tracy sounds like a
90s Bay Area rapper or something like
Dre hyphen C you know from Oakland or
something yeah Tracy sounds like he'd
have a song with like spice one or
something all right you ready for the
other one okay a shot of you ashadia
yeah yo [__] lit yeah bro I don't
know where the [__] these names like I
have a shot of your best tequila yeah
can I have a shot of your best tequila
you hear me yeah it's like that you know
see Yo shout out to your mom she's
[__] lit she was drunk next time I
have a kid I'm gonna call you I'm gonna
say I need I need your mom to name my
mom to name my kid yo it'll be some wild
[__] yeah nah yeah you don't want that
though bro I don't know what my mom was
thinking you know people be trying to be
different though shout out to her I love
her mom if you see this interview I love
is your mama very proud of you yes my
mom is very proud of me have you ever
had your mom call you about some Like
lyrics and like what the [__] is this
yeah hell yeah yeah hell yeah on the
album I said something about a dude she
was dating oh what'd you say
um the new album it's coming out yeah I
thought I was talking about this guy
named Terence who uh
man he was trying to he was trying to
get with my mom and I I guess it kind of
didn't work and he put us out we was
homeless he kicked y'all out kicked us
out it was homeless yeah she [__] my
mom
and it didn't and when you were a kid
yeah Terence I mean but they grown
though ain't no telling what happened
she probably I don't know you want to
hear it yeah but still to kill me kids
out you know like you gotta go the kids
could stay he kicked us off you gotta
get the [__] out of here he kicked us
out damn so what I wonder what Terence
is doing nowadays yeah I wonder what
Terence is doing so what did Mom be like
yo what the [__] I don't know how my
mama feel about me talk about this hey
Mom
when you're talking about it on the
[__] house my phone that let me call
my mom
let me let me let me call my mom real
quick bring my phone we got it we gotta
call Mom Dukes again call Mom and let's
figure out what happened with Taylor
let's figure out unplug it what was
gonna be the name of the next kid had
she had one all right
let's call him your mom's gonna answer
right yeah of course my mom loves me
that's a serious case on your phone I
respect it Bottega it's just the type of
case yeah yeah I'm chilling Ma
on you see she loved me I told you hey
Mom what happened
we're in the middle of an interview with
your son my name is Kevin
um
you have a special talent of naming your
children amazing names
yes you did well you should
yeah okay you should write a baby name
book uh too what happened with you and
Terence
all right listen listen you don't gotta
you don't you listen hold on you don't
got to tell him what but listen am I
okay to talk about this on the interview
okay nothing bad happened all right
oh yes he was a blessing he's gonna see
this interview and get so much Play
Chance was a great guy
[Music]
being an amazing friend who did
something all right God bless
you to death hey
I ain't finna go say nothing
you good
I'm trying to figure out what you want
hey hey hey uh I'm gonna call you later
and I'll tell you
I love you bye Mom love you love you I
love you nothing uh
um
hey not listen uh when I was a little
bit younger Mike couldn't do that
but
she got to go now cause uh she's like
Terence is a great guy and he's a great
friend and he is a blessing Hey Boy
[__] know what you did I'm a home [__]
know what he did but
here